is once again a Battlefield
supporters of iraqish Southern gathered
here to protest against the
Parliamentary session that saw one of
their main allies joining ranks with
sudra's rivals
we don't have rights like in other
countries what did we do
want the framework to form the
government we are fed up
Iraq is for Iraqis not for Iran we don't
want to be proxies security forces close
the entrances to the green zone but
protesters didn't give up security
forces were pushed back from the rear
Square where now there is no sign of
them anymore if you look just behind me
here they can be seen on al-jumuria
bridge where protesters are trying to
make their world over this bridge
towards the other area
they wanted to storm the green zone
where political blocks convened in the
parliament to vote on the speaker's
resignation it was the first
parliamentary meeting since August when
fighting broke out between supporters of
sadar and his Shi arrivals killing more
than 30 people Muhammad al-busi wanted
the MPS who replaced sato's 73 deputies
to confirm his previous election by
refusing his resignation as expected he
kept his position and MPS from the
southwest Rivals the iran-back
coordination framework voted in favor
minutes after the session a couple of
rockets struck the green zone winning
four security Personnel bulldozers
allegedly owned by sadris supporters was
seen removing High walls on the
entrances of the zone and many fear they
might be preparing to occupy the
parliament once again